dire l'amour est dans le pré a explosé
4,1 millions de téléspectateurs
il était loin devant france 2 est
deuxième et f1 c'est la cata un
joséphine dit une autre fosse des
finances gardien 3,2 millions de
téléspectateurs
secrets d'histoire bas ils sont restés
un petit peu dans le secret et voilà
drive drive c'est un mec qui va aux
balles et d'autres équipements de cheese
clash assez mémorable dans l'émission
que c'est maïté la prétendante de paul
henry qui a fait mal digéré le fait de
se faire éconduire par l'agriculteur
maïté alors là elle a fait parler d'elle
toute la journée
arrivé l été on était devant je préfère
rester avec elle fait que tu connais pas
plutôt que d'être avec quelqu'un qui
tend à montrer l'allemand qui avait fait
spontané de joux viala
déconneur comme toi et au final je te
mets avec quelqu'un qui est une pro
verte' et j'espère que vous allez bien
vous faire chier et j'espère que tu le
regretteras c'est vraiment bon mais
n'appelle pas ça sert à rien je te le
dire tu peux textoter à tout et
messenger moi tu oublies pas une femme
rigolote et spontané que tu cherches une
femme soumise en fait qu'ils se plient à
tes désirs je sais pas
elle laisse partir je suis quelqu'un de
deuil que je suis rayon de soleil
je le sais tout ça va les revoir alors
allez l maïté la pauvre elle s'est faite
fracas sur les réseaux sociaux là les
sympathiques elle est franchement elle
est dans ce cas quand même est-ce que
vous êtes choqué par le comportement de
l'enfant une émission de télé réalité
qui ressemble vraiment à la réalité
bien sûr on a tous une somme comme ça
quand on s'est fait quitter on a tous
été un peu trop vieux mais chut est ici
quelle somme de cette pépite est
acquitté mais arrêtez cela dit c'est
l'histoire de sa vie
battre à mains nues non ça n'est jamais
arrivé vous avez toujours quitter vos
mecs non mais où l on se sépare et on
s'endort
alors je vous dis alors et je le dis aux
téléspectateurs sans la meuf où le mec
me dit non s'est séparé d'un commun
accord
c'est sûr et certain que c'est l'autre
personne mais c'est sûr d'un commun
accord il m'a dit j'ai plongé plus de
voix que doit donc l'assassin d'un
commun accord oui juste un petit détail
sur la séquence ont bouclé la jeune
femme est en train de fumer ils ont
shooté à la production ça montre que
c'est une séquence vrai cet art dont il
ne savait pas tourné ils ont shooté ça
en off et ça prouve bien que c'est des
séquences sincère et c'est bizarre c'est
quand même la prod qui l'a ramené cette
jeune fille n'avait pas le candidat
qu'il a choisi donc je me demande je ne
crie pas lâcher au riz du complot mais
vu qu'ils connaissent les rouages que ça
un tempérament de feu qu'elle va faire
des étincelles
est-ce que c'est pas fait exprès de
l'avoir amiard des sciences a fait de
lui un amorti fanni vers des départs de
maïté ya paul henry qui a décidé
d'inviter son autre prétendante aline il
avait décidé d'ailleurs son nom sur une
sortie pour les tourtereaux rire de
souvenirs place câline air a agi d'une
façon assez surprenante en bougeant ses
plats regardez
[Musique]
que l'on gagne
frei
[Musique]
croiser un orgasme et pga tour du
dernier soir pour me donner des orgasmes
[ __ ] coc à chaud les mignonnes ali
d'un jean-michel aviez dire quelque
chose
oui non mais je trouve que audrey la
livraison ce que je trouve les
agriculteurs se comporte vraiment mal
avec les films cette année syfy ce n'est
pas l'amour est dans le pré
c'était vraiment la rage est dans le pré
ça va ya plus de 1 h et la pluie elles
plus donc de la ddt de scènes d'amour
dans l'amour est dans le pré l'irak
ça vous dirait vous de faire l'amour est
dans le pré ouais moi j'aimerais bien
servi ce que vous êtes célibataire je
crois oui j'assume mais je suis pas de
bouchon voilà ça veut dire j'ai un mec
plus ou moins où le mec a déjà neuf donc
bon a dit plus ou moins c'est à dire
j'ai un mec mais bon il m'a dit qu'il
ait quitté sa voie en fout deuxième
solution
si éventuellement je trouve new wave à
ses jours voilà c'est compliqué petit de
surfer je vis seule je respecte le
confinement on ne reviendra pas
là-dessus élèves bien entendu je crois y
est ré disais non mais elle disait voilà
elle disait à mon ami yann elle lui
disait je respecte le confinement
puisqu'il voulait à lille chez elle oui
non mais pas oui panneau est la patrie
il est également plombée
dans l'épisode d'hier on a également pu
assister à la fin de la romance entre
4,6 et françois visiblement ils sont pas
près de se revoir cette année oui le
faire fonctionner la saq h-19 h les
attentes par rapport à une femme dans
l'idéal chez de partager
partager des passions les voyages etc tu
aimeras you obama j'aimerais bien
retourner à saint domingue toi j'ai été
après toi j'ai pas réfléchi plus que sa
destination et c'est pas ce qui manque
toi puis donc tout ce temps on se tient
au courant et je t'appelle ya pas de
souci je pense qu'on restera en contact
de toute façon si tu voulais hop on
verra bonne route en tout cas je me
tiens pas partie ça va le faire une fois
parties sont d'accord il et il n'est pas
du tout fait pour la campagne il est
fait pour rien à lorient
il est fatigué si ce n'est pas à vendre
a indiqué se couche pas pressé la bm en
quoi il est charmé les pénibles bien sûr
les mamies mais sait on rêvait le
casting est fait exprès pour que oui oui
ça fait un bien fou d'amour ils sont
tellement fait nommer le père du garçon
il a peur d'un guerrier qui malgré
toujours une exception
regardez mes amis j'ai regardé bah oui
il faut le différend opposant puisque
les deux balades et des gens qui
n'avaient au coeur il ya rien à se dire
enfin vous êtes célibataire montbel this
alors non depuis peu de temps
alors oui elle a trouvé chaussure à son
pied mais il faut mettre un chausse-pied